we think he's outstanding we think he's
our quarterback of the future
we just couldn't get together at this
particular time
i think it's easily worth noting that
a lot of people this year in the
franchise mode
didn't get together one of the biggest
reason is the backdrop
of of the covet one of the biggest
reason is the economic issue
i've just spent weeks and weeks a part
of this rash voice on the phone
talking with nfl and the players
association
weeks and weeks working through the
economic
consequences and candidly nobody knows
what's going to be there next year next
year or the next year
and frankly we all know that what we
were talking about in dak's case was the
next year and the next year and the next
year and the next year
so all of that came to bear and this was
just
a less than stable time
to be talking about serious serious
generationally if you will to use tax
term dollars
in an unknown period of time looking
forward business is business and once
i'm in the uh in the locker room and
part of this uh
part of what's going on now i don't
focus too much about the future uh just
more about today
um so with that being said i'm excited
as hell to be a dallas cowboy
i've been a fan of this organization and
been a fan of this program for
for years i love every bit of the
opportunity and the platform that i get
to be the quarterback here
i love this team i'm excited about what
we have uh what we what we can do and
accomplish this year so
um no frustration as far as that uh once
again i believe something will get done
and with my hopes i believe i'll be a
dallas cowboy for the rest of my career
i don't think anybody's been able to
compartmentalize football and business
better than dak prescott i think at the
end of the day shereen that's the reason
why he has never
buckled he has never just said okay
enough money is enough money
generational is generational it doesn't
need to be a giant capital g
generational i can just take the cowboys
offer of generational money even though
i can work this system to my advantage
if i treat it more like a business
he has treated it like a business i
think now look maybe there are others
who have done it as well but i can't
think of anyone who has done it better
than dak prescott where he can just wall
off
the business aspects focus on football
take care of football business
which sets him up even better for
business business
and the cowboys have never hidden mike
their agenda of trying to separate
players from agents and talk to players
individually and trying to sell them on
the deal
this is why we want to give you this
deal let us spell it out for you
and they tried to do that with that
prescott and he called his agent
todd france and said should i talk to
the cowboys any and he wouldn't do it
and he didn't go
for the deal in the end at the 11th hour
as that
as uh dez bryant we saw him do that in
2014. the same thing
transpired and he ended up signing the
deal at the 11th hour and
and so dak didn't go for that and he he
did
compartmentalize as you said football
and business and and he does do it very
well
and the fact that he didn't get a deal
done won't affect him at all
he'll be just fine on the football field
he'll do what he needs to do and
in fact or facts he's going to make 31
million this year which is
27 28 million more than he's made in his
career so far
on the field of course he's made a lot
more off the field as quarterback of the
dallas cowboys so
i do think he ends up staying with the
cowboys but the fact that they didn't
get it done
obviously leaves some doubt in there
whether they do get it done or not
we played jerry's comments yesterday
along with some words from steve and my
reaction at the end of it was i love
both of those guys i love what they've
done for football but i'm not buying
their explanation
the explanation the truth is they have
consistently
underestimated dak prescott's resolve
they have underestimated his willingness
to say
no thank you i will go with door number
two
i'm not interested in door number one
and you know from a conceptual
standpoint i think this is so important
for players and agents to understand
the cowboys created this mess
specifically by applying the franchise
tag
they used a right available to them
under the collective bargaining
agreement to restrict a player whose
contract had expired
from becoming a free agent they made the
first move in this game of chess
and they decided to make a big move by
not simply using the non-exclusive tag
that would have cost
27 million or so this year but also
would have opened the door for someone
to try to pill for dak prescott
if they were willing to give up a couple
of first-round draft picks the cowboys
went with the cadillac
option 31.4 million exclusive franchise
tender sends a message this is our guy
and that's when dr prescott sits down
and starts doing the math shereen and
i've been saying this all along
it doesn't matter what russell wilson
makes it doesn't matter what patrick
mahomes makes it doesn't matter where
the market's going or where the cap is
once you apply that exclusive franchise
tag dak prescott has clear rights
31.4 million this year 37.68 million
next year if they tag him again if not
he gets to become a free agent and we'll
see what the market will bear
and then the kirk cousins slash
armageddon situation for the cowboys in
2022.
45 million under the transition tag 54
million under the franchise tag 54
million
under the franchise tag if they want to
keep him for that third year or
let him hit the market and i've been
saying this all along because people
like what's stack prescott really worth
what's his market value well the cowboys
have kept us from finding out
and their effort to keep us from finding
out has put him in a position
where he can start down this path where
he makes nearly 70 million over two
years
and then maybe ends up on the open
market
well and mike the three deals that we
saw yesterday really
undermine their excuse of well kovet
played
into this the unknown economic landscape
played into this in the future
we saw huge deals yesterday with dion
dawkins with the bills and travis kelsey
and
and george kittle we saw all those big
deals happen
and and obviously the deadline has
passed the cowboys can't do that deal
now but they could have done that deal
before july 15th
and the fact is they didn't want to play
dak prescott what he wanted
he wanted to fight he wanted a four-year
deal the cowboys wanted a five-year deal
and the guaranteed money that they were
offering on a five-year deal
wasn't enough and so that's why they are
where they are at this point
and wondering if dak prescott will be
their quarterback beyond this season
something that they thought
i guarantee you was unfathomable
a year ago they've been working on this
thing for more than a year and they
couldn't get it done
and and here's the thing you know you
can hide behind
the notion that there's financial
uncertainty and look there is
and the salary cap may be only 175
million next year
but one thing we've seen time and again
during the age of the salary cap
there are devices for managing the
cap there are ways to pay your best
players
and kick the can down the road with
other players
to try to make it all fit in any given
year
and really it's far more challenging for
the cowboys next year
to go forward with dak prescott having a
cap number of 37.68 million it can't be
reduced without a long-term deal
that's his salary that's his cap hit
next year
and if the salary cap is 175
and your quarterback has taken up 37.68
of it
you got a far bigger problem than giving
dak the contract he wanted now
and trying to make it fit under the cap
next year so i i don't buy
any of that look the truth is
they have made they being the cowboys
consistently bad decisions
about dak prescott's resolve they've
underestimated him you know tony romo
end of the day
agreed and took the cowboys offer and it
was a team-friendly offer and they've
seen it over and over again where they
ultimately get what they want like you
said shireen they throw their arm around
the guy
and they talk him into doing the deal
dax the first one who stood up to them
and said no i'm not doing it and i don't
think they know how to handle it
well and you look at the chiefs mike you
talk about fitting it under the cap
remember when the chiefs had less than
two hundred dollars two hundred dollars
not two hundred thousand not two million
two hundred dollars under the salary cap
and they've been able to get all their
core players
signed long term and they've done it and
they've rearranged contracts to get that
done and they are set and they
hear the cowboys sit well it's covered
well it's a financial landscape we can't
get this done
right now that had nothing to do with it
it is the fact that
dak had this resolve that they were just
unprepared for and
and now they are where they are of
course it helps that the chiefs got
their
franchise quarterback to accept a
contract that has
a horribly low signing bonus abysmal
cash flow over the next few years i mean
dak prescott and peop
you know when i made the argument after
the homes deal was
was announced and we saw the numbers
that there's no way dak prescott would
take that deal people thought i was nuts
i mean i've given them plenty of reasons
over the years to come to that
conclusion but on this one i'm not
dak would not take that deal especially
when you look at the most important
metrics signing bonus
guaranteed money fully guaranteed money
at signing and cash flow over the first
three years the mahomes deal is
horrendous and what dak would make over
the next three years and which
was was gonna make this year 31-4 this
year patrick holmes making 10 11 million
dollars this year
the the first three years the next three
years just blows my homes away
and at the end of those three years if
dak does go year to year under the
franchise tag
he goes wherever he wants mahomes is
still locked up for nine more years with
the chiefs
the biggest mistake mike that i think
the cowboys made was not getting this
deal done before jared goff before
carson wentz and they had an opportunity
to do that and they didn't do that and
those two deals came out and i was like
oh my gosh you can't pay dac press got
that kind of money he's not worth that
and now when you look at the carson
winsteal and the jared goff deal they
look pretty darn good if they had done
it back then
the cowboys would be sitting in great
shape to me that was the biggest mistake
they made was not getting that deal done
long ago well before he played his
fourth season and played out his
contract
and here's the thing that i keep waiting
for a team to do that has that young
quarterback that they know
based upon his first three seasons he's
our guy
whether it's lamar jackson this year
entering season three with the ravens
or next year kyler murray your favorite
entering year three with the arizona
cardinals shireen doesn't like kyler
because he transferred from texas a
m so anyway kyle murray next year uh
once you know and the cardinals already
know now but they can't
give him the second contract until the
third season ends
specifically and i've looked at this
time and again in the cba to make sure
i'm not missing something
it's when the third regular season ends
that's when you can sign that extension
so what you do when the player is in
that third
season and he's getting closer and
closer to the end of the regular season
that's when you start negotiating you're
allowed to negotiate before you're
allowed to do the deal i mean
technically the cowboys and dak prescott
could be negotiating now the deal that
they'd sign after this regular season
ends if they want to do it
you start negotiating with that young
quarterback and you put your best offer
on the table the moment the regular
season ends
and he's going to take it he's going to
take it then
because he still has games to be played
playoff games to be played if he's you
know as good as
as you think he is and he's positioning
himself for a huge payday you should be
in the playoffs
you get him to sign that contract before
that first playoff game you take the
injury risk off his shoulder
before that playoff game after his third
season you get the deal done as soon as
the third regular season ends
i'm amazed no one's done that and
sharing i think if the cowboys would
have done that
and gotten dak prescott the best offer
they would have made at the time
before the seahawks wild card game after
the 2018 season
would have been a hell of a lot less
money than what they're looking at
spending now
absolutely no question about it and
that's where they fell they failed
a year ago a year and a half ago more
than they failed
now um not getting this deal done before
july 15th
so i you know i think the cowboys as you
said that they thought they could talk
dak prescott into this deal they've done
it so many
times with so many players they thought
they could put
their what they think is their best deal
on the table and say here's the reasons
we need you to take this team
hey they said it publicly stephen jones
and jerry jones both said publicly we
need dac to take a team
friendly deal that's what they continue
to call it a team friendly deal
and dax said it's not my job to
to manage your cap you've got to manage
your cap
i'm going to get my generational money
and he is gonna end up getting his
generational money whether it's with the
cowboys or with somebody else
there is that spectrum with peyton
manning at one end who always had that
attitude my job is to play quarterback
your job is to manage the cap
and then there's tom brady at the other
end who took the team friendly deals and
again
he didn't take the team friendly deals
because he had this master plan that
he's going to win six super bowls and
he's going to consciously take less
money
he took the team friendly deals because
he was scared to death he was going to
have a bloated cap number one year
and bill belichick was going to kick his
butt to the curb like belichick did with
drew bledsoe
that's why tom brady took team-friendly
deals in new england
but i never know where a quarterback is
going to land on that spectrum and dak
prescott is right there next to peyton
mann
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports